demon souls begins with the old one an
eldritch great one descending upon the
earth once awakened it inspires a
hierarchy of demons dedicated to the
retrieval of every soul in exchange for
great power in the evil ending deep
below the Nexus every soul is given to
the old one and a great fog blankets the
world
yawns later deep below a gray land
covered in fog for hollow beings
discover an immense amount of souls and
the story of Dark Souls begins the fog
is dispersed civilization is reborn and
Souls flourish anew however the
irrevocable poison of the old one
persists and eventually humanity looks
for an escape from this cursed world
they find a way out through a painted
world of blood and as the tale of
blood-borne begins humanity creeps ever
closer to the eldritch truth that
they've forgotten strengthened by the
echoes of the past found within the
blood this is an argument for the shared
timeline of the souls borne universe and
I'll be honest it's kind of a lesson in
how easy it can be to push an
entertaining theory just as long as you
cherry-pick only the evidence that suits
your narrative it's really dishonest to
tell a story in that way but it is a lot
of fun so from your perspective I hope
it's interesting for you to sort of try
and find the gaps that I'm leaving in my
logic first let's establish that the old
one is a great one from Lovecraftian
fiction so the great ones as described
by HP Lovecraft are cosmic deities that
are so inconceivable and horrific to
humanity that they often shatter the
minds of those who encounter them as an
example of this let me introduce you to
these renditions of oz' Thoth and
shub-niggurath both of whom are very
similar in some ways to the old one of
demon souls so as a
is commonly called the nuclear chaos the
blind idiot God who resides at the
center of the universe he rules all time
and space yet his chaotic and really
unpredictable idiotic nature inspires
this fear that he could accidentally
bring about the end of the world at any
time according to Lovecraft as a Thoth
is lulled by the thin monotonous piping
of a demonic flute and many writers of
Lovecraftian fiction take this music as
an attempt to soothe as a Thoth and his
chaos into a dormant loud state
similarly of course the old one of demon
souls also appears to lack intelligence
it's also wholly capable of bringing
about the end of the world as the last
time it was awakened it erased half the
world in fog this world was only saved
by the efforts of the monumentals
who loved the great one back to slumber
and said about preserving the fabric of
reality that remained sound familiar
consider also shub-niggurath mother of a
thousand young who is depicted as this
great floating entity made of mouths
tentacles and lesser creatures that
emerge from its body this being is the
subject of a lot of worship and in fact
it consumes its most worthy worshipers
and then spits them out as an immortal
being so again this is not unlike our
widely worshipped old one which is also
a great floating entity which spawned
all of daemon kind and one who consumes
the slayer of demons at the end of the
game in return for great power
in addition like many of Blood Bones
great ones the old one comes from the
ocean not only that but like Lovecraft's
great ones the old ones very nature
cannot be fathomed by the living and
finally there's a place called latria
in Demon Souls which you should remember
from your PTSD if you've played the game
and latria is actually a theological
term for worship in this place many have
been evolved to a higher state of being
thanks to their proximity to their God
whom it is revealed is the old one and a
lot of these transformations are
definitely Lovecraftian in style so
while I don't recommend you buy into
this shared timeline theory that I'm
pedaling one thing you absolutely can
take from this is just how far back from
software's Lovecraftian inspirations go
it's the cosmic horror of the old one
that makes it such a great antagonist
for demon souls 100% and once it lures
you to its side in the evil ending when
all souls have been channeled into this
unfathomable deposit of energy when a
grey deep fog envelops the world we have
the perfect transition into the Dark
Souls universe where millennia later
it's easy to imagine latent hollows
stumbling upon these souls of Lords deep
below the earth these souls from the old
one have combusted to create the first
flame and when you think about it the
body of the old one would have made for
fantastic kindling so these four husks
inherit the condensed souls of the old
one deep below the earth and with phage
they dispel the gray fog that's above
them because a soul after all as defined
by the monumental is the essence with
which living things comprehend the world
around them fog actually represents a
lack of clarity and with souls hollows
are granted the clarity to pee
is the fog demon cells actually has one
of the best and only definitions of the
concepts of souls and folk in their
souls universe and so a new world is
created by the Lord's and the structure
of this world is really similar to the
world of demon souls a core law of the
world is that the strong will always
dominate the weak and souls will
naturally coalesce towards powerful
entities as a result of this the chosen
Undead the bearer of the curse the ashen
one every iteration of this world moves
towards a state of entropy where all the
souls are held by one being just like it
did in Demon Souls and this process is
assisted by a maiden who's able to
channel Souls in every game perhaps it's
no surprise that these maidens began to
obscure their sight and dress in black
over time just like their ancestor once
did notice how this new world also
retains the twin arts of miracles and
sorcery and just like in Demon Souls
it's rumored that both these arts share
the same source in demon souls for
example the talisman of beasts reveals
that both miracles and sorceries draw
upon the power of the old one and in
Dark Souls there are items like velka's
talisman which reveal that miracles can
indeed be cast with intelligence alone
and sorceries paradoxically with faith
you might ask what is pyromancy then and
even demon souls explains that because
demon souls had flame sorcery and Dark
Souls mentions that flame sorcery was
once a thing and of course at the core
of Dark Souls is the curse in every age
there's this effort to gain insight into
this cursed existence as kings and
scholars both attempts to look deeper
into souls for answers and an
however the soul and the curse are one
in the same the soul is the cause the
Coase is irrevocably tied to the soul
reminding us of a certain poison that
was placed upon the earth millennia ago
on the first day mankind was granted a
soul and on the second upon earth was
planted an irrevocable poison a soul
devouring demon the curse is
characterized by being sold of Aaron and
the old ones poison is irrevocable just
like the curse and I think that when it
consumed every soul in demon souls for
the lords to eventually absorb at the
start of Dark Souls it became an
inseparable part of souls themselves a
curse a poison the only thing that
transcends the soul and the poison of
the old one
is whatever God placed them there on the
first and second day of creation and so
if one one senses one would have the
glance towards the heavens so as we move
towards blood-borne consider Chester of
all the seal he's dressed in a hunter's
attire
he has rose daggers that cause bleeding
and he also favors a crossbow in a world
without guns Chester
looks like he belongs in yharnam not all
the seal and indeed perhaps he's proof
that yharnam is what the future holds
hmm let me guess snatched by a shadowy
limb and dragged off to the Past yes of
course exactly what happened to me
we are both strangers in this strange
land
so if blood-borne takes place in the
future how did the inhabitants of this
world get there how did they escape the
curse of their own Souls and the answer
as characters in souls slowly began to
realize was blood a substance which is
mentioned more and more as the series
progresses get this in Dark Souls 2 the
drake blood knights began to worship the
blood of dragons which they believed
would allow them to understand life and
transcend existence concepts that are
very familiar to blood-borne players in
Dark Souls 3 the sacred blood of the
wolf was spread amongst the abyss
watchers and their souls became one with
the soul of the wolfblood master it's a
first sign that blood is sort of a
vessel for souls and the coast in ashes
of arendelle we see Bloods ability to
appease the flame just like a soul and
in the ringed City the primal linked
blood is confirmed with gales
consumption of the blood of the Dark
Soul and its subsequent retrieval for
the creation of arias painting so
vendrick believed that the answer to the
curse lay within the soul itself but in
reality to escape we would have to
understand that blood is a powerful
human defining resource just like souls
are and so with the world painted with
the most primal blood imaginable
humanity separates their cursed Souls
from the blood leaving the old ones
poison behind and escaping the world of
Dark Souls traveling or borne by blood
to a new world but they can become
closer to the insight that they create
symbolically Yanam ends up being built
above the chalice dungeons below and
many of these contain knights in plate
armor from the medieval times of demons
and Dark Souls in this world of
blood-borne blood alone contains the
powerful echoes of the past and the
concept of a soul no longer exists hence
the curse no longer exists humanity now
relying on blood instead of the souls
that they left behind has escaped the
irrevocable poison of the old one but
they remain under the influence of great
ones just like it similar to how Demon
Souls resolves directly around the old
one the story of blood-borne revolves
directly around the revelations about
the great ones many of which can be
extended to the old one as well the
motivations of these elder beings are
mysterious and they're incomprehensible
to mankind except for one thing
childbirth the great ones crave children
yet paradoxically their children are
always destined to die to solve this
problem they often have surrogate
children through humans viewed in this
way the old one is no different to the
great ones in blood-borne think about it
it's an entity with the goal of grooming
a child called a slayer of demons and
the old one itself had to die as well
in order for its poison to survive
interestingly there is an undeniable
link to demon souls that ended up being
cut from blood-borne early and
development
the word who basa in Demon Souls umbasa
was a word of reverence that was often
spoken by priests and miracle users
listen to Gascoigne's dialogue which was
present in the network test sea creature
may you rest in peace
Massa and to this random Jana might
extracted from the game's files only
recently give your blessing and wash
from us the blood of base Goomba saw the
use of this word hints at a rediscovery
of a god that was introduced in Demon
Souls and lost in Dark Souls a God that
granted humans a soul but also granted
them the poison of the old one this was
a litany of stories that eventually
ended in the Ascension of mankind in
blood-borne to a new eldritch childhood
where they are finally on even footing
with the so-called gods that started it
all
that does it for this video which is
probably like one of the most bizarre
things I've ever made on this channel
because it was a strange experience for
me
I just tried my hardest to sell you on
something I don't really believe and I
ignored my logic a lot of the time when
writing this script in order to sell it
to you better did you think I was
successful did I fail did you notice any
difference compared to my other videos
I'd love to see you rip apart this
theory in the comments please go ahead
remember this was the most voted for
video by patrons a couple of months ago
and I hope I delivered for you guys so
thanks to all of you guys who supported
my channel back then and now it's
incredibly heartening to still have so
many of you giving a couple of dollars
to support something you love I'll keep
doing this and I'll see you next time